surprise surprise Ashley Graham and her
hubby Justin Irvin found the perfect way
to celebrate their nine-year anniversary
with a pregnancy announcements this is
pretty exciting the couple shared the
happy news on Wednesday posting this
sweet video to Instagram the model
captioned the adorable baby bump reveal
quote nine years ago today I married the
love of my life it has been the best
journey with my favorite person in the
world
adding today we are feeling so blessed
grateful and excited to celebrate with
our growing family happy Anniversary mr.
justin urban life is about to get even
better I found the most amazing man that
I you know I love and adore who's my
best friend also meanwhile Justin shared
a sweet pic of himself and Ashley with a
sonogram writing in part now that we've
made a life together let's make a life
together I love you and I love us all of
us the parents-to-be have been married
since 2010 we dated for a year before
them we met in church in New York at
this place called the journey and I was
in the elevator
bringing people up the elevator and he
came in and said hey girl and Ashley
revealed the secret behind their lasting
love one of the things that we say is
don't go to bed mad at each other
because when you wake up the whole rest
of your days is just jacked up we have a
rule we don't go longer than two weeks
without seeing each other and it's
absolutely fabulous I love it so we just
need in LA or New York we meet in Paris
Miami it's pretty sexy Ashley also
opened up to ET about waiting until
marriage to have sex with Justin there
was already the sexual tension of just
roaring this but we had already
established such a friendship that we
had the two combined which and my eyes
just made magic because now not only am
i sleeping with somebody that I trust
and I love but I know that he wants me
and he he
firms me all the time unless we know how
sexy and beautiful I am and the couple
has had babies on the brain for a while
now we're totally gonna have kids we're
probably gonna do it in the next few
years
yeah and just another part of my brain
building
[Music]
[Applause]